look at my big old bag of spinach and
maybe if i cut him up really small
he'll like them you want to eat some
when the toes get going he's excited
what is some green stuff what is this
try this bite that i get for you
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okaiest
mom and i have a very picky eater i feel
like there's always at least
one in each house in our case it's my
son wyatt he's not very into
experimenting or trying new things so
i want to challenge myself i am going to
try to get him to eat a vegetable
in every meal for one entire week so
let's see if i can pull this off wish me
luck
so let's get into the rules i can hide
the veggies however i see fit i can get
as creative as i want in the execution
i'm going to focus on vegetables that
both boys have previously
refused to even taste i'm going to tell
the boys that i'm trying a week of new
recipes
new and exciting foods so that a they're
excited to try my food
and b they don't know what's going on
i'm not going to show you every single
meal of every single day because then
this video would be
40 minutes long and if at the end of
this week the boys liked more foods than
they disliked
i'm going to treat the entire family to
their favorite takeout
because i need a break from cooking this
is going to be a lot of cooking
i'm going to show you how i make a
smoothie with vegetables
the smoothie consists of frozen banana
frozen blueberries
frozen cauliflower it's a perfect
smoothie addition because it blends
really nicely and adds
great texture because i have the wild
blueberries
they make the smoothie really dark so i
can add some spinach
and nobody really minds top it off with
some
milk of your choice add some protein
powder
this just makes it a hardier smoothie
and then i added my
secret ingredient which is spirulina
it's super nutrient rich
and you only need a tiny amount to get
all of the nutrients that it delivers
something very compelling for my kids is
when you title the food like it's
something special and thematic
it looks black so this is a
witch's brew smoothie it tastes like
cantaloupe sure as long as you're
drinking it
it can taste like whatever you want that
my friends is the face
of a satisfied customer you're dancing
with your smoothie
the boys loved it day one safe bet
success on today too i love
beads they have a nice texture and
flavor in my opinion
my kids do not agree but i figured day
two let's go for it the time of day that
the boys are most hungry is breakfast
so if i'm trying something that i'm not
so sure about that's
probably the optimal time to do it
because they're very hungry
i mix the beets with greek yogurt and
some water and i use that in my protein
pancake mix
and what it created was this beautiful
pink color
which is super appetizing it looked like
a candy color
the only thing i wasn't quite sure about
was whether or not you could taste the
beets because i did add
quite a few i went a little too healthy
on this one but
that'll be fine t-rex all right
go ahead this looks good
you like it that's good
just wailing for more it's good huh
i will be making these again absolutely
day two
i was on a roll so i decided to try
something a little more difficult
day three i decided to bring back an old
friend of mine knock knock who's fair
it's an impasta spaghetti squash
a long time ago i decided to try that
and they
loved it and then matt chimed in
matt turns them and says yeah and you
know that's squash right
they both push their plates away and
we'll never taste it again
i thought he had my back i figured it
had been enough time since the spaghetti
squash
incident of 2017 that i could bring it
back
i'm gonna cut this in half coat it in
olive oil and seasoning pop it in the
oven
and then the magic happens now the
beauty of these
is that you just take a fork and shred
it and then
toss it in some marinara oh man
it looks pretty good i served dinner and
then went and put henry to bed so i
didn't get
the genuine reaction of the boys eating
the food you like it
really good they didn't complain i don't
think they were thrilled
i think it's something we could do again
but the person who enjoyed it the most
was the person who ratted me out all
those years ago
i ate three plates delicious so i will
categorize that as a win
move on to day four let's make ramen
i swear every time i get super confident
days one two and three and then day four
i get very humbled
wyatt loves ramen don't come for me it's
very bland looking
i know he has a bland palette we
are working on it hence this video
try to add some veggies into it and see
if he notices
and maybe if i cut him up really small
he'll like them i added way too much
whoops but this is with the spinach it's
a lot i probably did a little too much
maybe i'm the reason why my kids won't
eat certain foods because i overdo it
what is it oh for extra seasoning and
flavor should i make this again
just like that what do you think jackson
it's delicious i think it only worked
because i chopped the spinach up really
tiny
now if i had served my kids full leaves
of cooked spinach
they would have gagged until they threw
up at the dinner table it has happened
before
day four i overshot it a bit but we made
it through and they ate it
and my next food i'm going to tackle is
sweet potatoes wyatt really doesn't like
these
i had the thought of adding sweet
potatoes
into pumpkin bread the flavors of
pumpkin and sweet potato are
kind of similar so it would probably
blend in really well i'm gonna grate
some sweet potatoes into this pumpkin
bread mix and bake them off like muffins
i think it'll be good and this is when
my cover was almost blown
it's muffins but what is this kids
hover my children hover like vultures
every time i'm preparing food i'm hungry
wait for the muffins okay
let's sweeten the deal those dinosaur
picks have been a
game changer it really makes any meal
exciting for them
that's amazing it's amazing
oh my gosh
i'm gonna try this one i'm excited tasty
the muffins were a resounding success
henry even got to taste it
i did feel like i cheated a little bit
in that one
because the food was borderline dessert
so i tacked another meal onto the week
it is pasta night 2.0
i have some pasta boiling
i also have some zoodles half and half
it's like a hybrid
pasta dish i'm also going to add some
riced cauliflower to the sauce
so it's double veggie night and because
i know how much of a meat lover why it
is
i topped it off with meatballs
and he would not even touch
the noodles no the green stuff
try this bite that i get for you it just
has a little seasoning on it
okay what do you think how'd it taste
good okay are you gonna finish it
onto meatballs he said that he liked it
but
what he liked was the meatballs he
didn't really eat the pasta we all have
wins and we all have losses but overall
i'm still doing well
i'm in my row because i'm feeling fancy
because today we're going to try
something a little bit difficult and i
just want to be as comfortable as
possible
one food that i can never
get quiet to even attempt to try is
brussels sprouts
i decided to treat the brussels sprouts
like a vegetable
crouton of sorts so i cut them up pretty
small
seasoned them generously and roasted
them that way so they got
extra crispy extra flavorful my boys
love caesar salad so i decided i was
going to take
these crispy shaved brussels sprouts and
incorporate them in a caesar salad why i
mixed a vegetable within another
vegetable
i don't know i also made so many
brussels sprouts it was more brussels
sprouts than lettuce
so it did not fool them at all wyatt has
a very specific order of eating when he
doesn't like something on his plate he
goes for the meat first
carbs second and then before he gets to
the thing he doesn't like he says he has
to go to the bathroom
what is this oh it's just part of the
salad try it
that's not salad yeah it is no
wyatt jackson my garbage disposal child
really enjoyed it
[Music]
ready it's a coupon go ahead
this coupon is a bellsprout your name is
coupon
i am done for the day
i'm going to bed if wyatt tries it and
still doesn't like it that's fair
day six didn't go as planned it was my
own fault
i decided day seven i needed to go out
strong
jackson hates mushrooms like if i want
to really make him mad
i'll say oh i'm making yours with extra
mushrooms and he gets so
upset so i made hybrid patties
that have really finely blended
in them so let me show you can you
believe that these are plant-based
so those look like real burgers let's
see how it goes
and then to just secure my win i topped
them with the dinosaur toppers
i just want to eat it go ahead
amazing you like it you like the new
recipes i'm trying
how's that burger treating you it's
really good you notice anything
different it was stupid
bread isn't anything different nothing's
different matt still doesn't know what i
did to that burger
matt has slowly become one of my other
children so
day seven was a big big
win do you remember i made all those
special foods for you
yeah did you like them a lot yeah
okay can i tell you a secret about them
what every
meal had a veggie hidden inside the
pumpkin muffins i made
i knew they had sweet potatoes but that
was so
yummy do you want to know what was in
the burgers
mushrooms and you said you liked it
am i being a sneaky mom sure but sneaky
for the right reasons
did i win this challenge yes the boys
liked more food than they didn't like
and they tried everything so take outs
on me
well that's it for this time i'm hannah
and what did you think was i being a
mean mom
would you try any of the meals i made
let me know on instagram and also
message me if you have any other
hidden veggie food ideas now if you'll
please excuse us we're going to enjoy
our favorite takeout look you've got
some green in your bowl are you gonna
eat that
this is salad you're gonna eat it yeah
till next time
[Music]
you